it is time for the BET will uh how's
this going to work and Richard what are
your plans here well this is another
thing too and I know
[Music]
whoa whoa whoa what are you talking
about I'm gonna get so much [__] for
this but in respect to my wife and
Eagles fans who what I like the eagles I
will not wipe my ass on an eagles
you take that [__] Philadelphia
Eagles jersey like a man and stick it up
your ass right now you're not allowed to
do that I'll never be up I would never
be able to set foot in Philly again if I
do that what are you talking about I
will not be seen on camera putting an
Eagles jersey in my ass I just JD shaved
his head and you're gonna [__] bomb
out of the you better shove something up
you're right you put Wolfie's helmet up
there listen listen though so let's do
something else then maybe if Will's up
for it listen I won so I I get a little
bit of leeway here no this was the bet
we agreed on take this classic Brian
Dawkins Jersey a Philly Legend and shove
it up your ass how about you shove it up
your own ass that's not the best thing
we agreed to sorry sir I mean uh JD I
know you're pissed at Richard go ahead I
mean
I'm not exactly pissed but I mean it's
like what the [__] this is what Richard
does I you know look at my [__] head
dude
you had no issues of me shaving my head
you're ready for me to shave my head and
do this do that and now and now I'm a
little discussion with this well will
you shave your pubes and let's give him
a puke beard right now I'll shave my
pubes you're gonna shave off your pubes
and we'll Gloom to Rich's face I love
that
oh my god
well you [__] backed out of the bed
do what you're supposed to do you better
wipe your ass with that Jersey
that's the other choice let's go to an
authority on football Ralph Sorella go
ahead first of all this is so [__]
lame on so many levels Richard you were
such a [__] [__] man just [__] do
it and if you're not gonna do it he's
got to glue pubes all over his face like
the wolf man not understand all right
I'll do that Ralph let's do it let's do
this let them fall off slowly don't you
wash them can even put a couple on my
tongue we'll uh we'll bring a mic with
you while you're shaving your boobs off
and get your ball hair too and some of
that taint hair yeah
I will cut off the door Barry we'll make
it a mole on Richard's face
[Music]
will when's the last you showered uh I
did shower yesterday but the pubes are
pretty long so I think it is
Will how's it going ah
I'm doing it it's hard to do a one-man
operation everything I got a pretty good
amount of pubes here I think oh [__] I
just caught my nuts oh no is that true a
little bit it's all right let me see
that pile of pubes
[Music]
oh my God look at that plate of food
it's a ton
I know the vilest color too it's long
too I did my best you know what oh my
God I deserve this I'm sorry you do you
do deserve it as well Richard uh this is
disgusting uh I'm sorry you won and now
you're doing this I know it's my own
fault though Howard you know what I did
make a bet and I'm welching on it so I
deserve this all right all right here we
go in there well yes what happens when
you cheat the Eagles you son of a [__]
[Music]
[Applause]
Richard has a Hitler mustache it looks a
little authentic it's all pubes
oh
my god he has a full now he has a full
must
oh okay all right all right all right
[Music]
I don't even know what to say
the pubes in my face
this is the best Super Bowl loss ever
man hey Richard hey Richard how about
them Jeeps
yeah I don't imagine winter right now by
the way Richard you have to go home that
way you have to show up at home and have
you want to answer the door shut up and
and tell her why you look this way right
you know what I gotta say something
about Jersey too it looks like a real
mustache and beard I'm kind of shocked
by how
oh
[Music]
that's good I can't even talk because
Will's tubes are in my mouth
Richard uh I'm trying to think who does
Richard look what is it will you
understand why like he won the BET his
face is covered I'm trying to be a good
sport because I changed the BET and this
is what I get so you know he looks like
Cliff Clavin from uh cheers
yes his teeth are covered in pubes
it's crazy oh my God you look like you
ate [__] Will's decorating
keeps pressing them in yeah
[Music]
it's good
yeah exactly right exactly pretty weird
ending to uh Richard winning the BET how
about them Chiefs
foreign